foreign
what's up Angela
Hi how are you all thank you for taking
my call I'm a bit nervous oh don't be
nervous Jade's good at this I'm not that
good so you're all right
you always say that but you're kind of
my favorite don't tell anybody else well
you just told me
she wasn't paying attention what's up
just kidding
um so I was calling
um because I wanted to see if there was
some new thing that I don't know that I
haven't tried to try and get my husband
on board and I found out about Dave
Ramsey about sevenish years ago whenever
um shortly after I got into church and
um I told my husband about it he wasn't
very excited and then he jumped on board
for a little bit we paid off a bunch of
bits
um and then he kind of fell off the
wagon we ended up getting debt free and
then got back into that
um and like in recent conversations he's
like why don't we just do our own plan
I'm like because this is a proven plan
like I know this works when you say fall
off the wagon
to the tune like what does that look
like because is that you know a couple
hundred dollars or is this like a couple
of thousands of dollars or is this like
tens of thousands of dollars
yeah oh uh Caitlyn
um no
um just like we were talking about
um buying a house and you know he's
listening to people that say you need a
credit score and like no you don't and
um so he ended up getting credit cards
and then we got a personal loan for a
basement remodel and
um I and this is in your is this just in
his name and you're against it or are
you going along with it
um I was against it
um it was in his name
um but I was a part of it too like One
credit card was in my name that he got
on his account
um
I'm gonna let John hit you up on this
because there's more here
yeah
you're married to a child
you're more his mom than you are his
wife right
yes yes and
you don't like fighting either
and
um maybe it's not unsafe but it's
probably not wise and so you just go
along with it
and at some point you have to say I'm
not going to be your mom anymore I want
to be your wife
yeah and my guess is
everything is getting put onto this plan
and this plan is getting all the blame
this plan gets all the success and what
hasn't happened is there's not been an
identity change in your marriage
and the identity change in the marriage
is
we are people who will never borrow
money again
ever
the house is on fire come hell or high
water we're not borrowing money
and a tool to make that identity a
reality is this plan
but we CA if you make the plan the good
guy and the bad guy all the time it's
easy to be like let's just come up with
our own
because I'm tired of fighting you and
you're married to an impulsive child
who wants what he wants right now I want
a new basement remodel and he sounds
like he watches a ton of Instagram
because
um
well because we live with his mom to
help her out and
um it was supposed to be a temporary
situation so that we could save up to
buy our own house and so the basement
was my own place my own space my
um
kind of like separation from her you
took out a loan to upgrade your your
mother-in-law's house
it wasn't like a it was I mean it was a
couple thousand dollars but like it's
almost paid off wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait I I gotta bust in for a second
I got busting for a second
um
can I just tell you until you if if you
have a mistake that you made
which I think that you taking out that
loan was a mistake and I think you do
too but if you keep saying yeah but and
it was just for this and it was because
and you keep like and it was my
husband's fault yeah and you keep saying
why it was okay then it's no longer a
mistake in your mind and you're more
likely to do it again as opposed to just
going we did that that was so dumb and
never again yeah we learned our lesson
do you see what I'm saying but the more
you caveat it with reasons why it was
okay the more likely you are to do it
again and I'm guessing your husband's
not going to get on board because you're
not on board
well I'm on board it's just trying no
you're not no girlfriend you are not on
board you borrowed money why are you
living in your in your mother-in-law's
basement
um because she's a widow and okay to
help her out and
um what did she need help with
um finances she doesn't
work
um I know he draws disability and things
so okay
it may be time for some
let me just say it like this if I found
myself in your situation
and it's not as though you have we're
dropped in here this is just a global
you've made some errors your husband's
made some errors you all found yourself
in this place
you are taking care of somebody who's
not working who's drawing
um uh
uh either Social Security or disability
it's just a big old mess
I would take my husband out for lunch or
for breakfast and again people always
ask me why I always say that because if
you take somebody out for dinner after a
couple of hours when you get to nine or
ten o'clock there's no more productive
business meetings happening so I have
something powerful about going for
breakfast or going for lunch when the
sun is still shining and you are able to
be clear-headed and for several hours in
a row and I want you and your husband to
decide
are we just gonna are we we're looking
at mom she's on disability her kids are
living in her basement because she
doesn't have any alternatives is this
the life that we want we want to chart
forward for ourselves or do we want to
look at each other and Say Never Again
never again
and that means starting with we're not
ever going to borrow money ever
that means we are going to always check
in with each other and be people of
honor and integrity with one another and
then with everybody else
and that means we are going to follow
this plan and we've got a laid out plan
here and honey I'm on board I've been
getting mad at you for not being on
board I haven't been on board either
and we're not going to live at my
mother-in-law's house she may at some
point move in with us because we're
going to take care of her that's great
but we're not going to
find our dignity and worth and stand up
tall by living in my mother-in-law's
basement
it's not how it's going to work so we're
gonna move out we're gonna get our own
place and we're gonna start building on
our own two feet and you're gonna have
to ask your husband to be a grown man
and not a child anymore all of this is
gonna have to start happening stay on
the line we're gonna I'm gonna send you
Financial Peace University for a year
the every dollar app and I'm going to
send you a copy of my book own your past
change your future I want you and your
husband to read that together